(audience cheering)
- We are celebrating
50 years of hip hop.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
So to kick off, we have
a very special guest
in the Wayfair VIP lounge.
He is one of the most
in-demand DJs on the planet.
He spun at both Obama Inaugurations,
as well as at Jay-Z and Beyoncé's wedding,
not too shabby.
Give it up for DJ Cassidy!
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
- Kelly!
- [Kelly] What's up, man?
- Oh, thank you for having me.
- So, DJ Cassidy, you've
been a DJ for a long time,
and they say a DJ was credited
with starting hip hop.
So can you tell us about that?
- In 1973,
a young woman by the
name of Cindy Campbell
asked her brother, Clive Campbell,
to throw a back to school
party in the South Bronx.
And that man's name was DJ Kool Herc.
He got all his vinyl and he put 'em out,
laid him out and said, "I'm
gonna create something new
by playing the breaks of
these obscure records."
And he played the
breakdowns of funk records,
disco records, soul records, r&b records,
and those people dancing to
the breaks of these records
became break dancers.
And this was the first hip hop
party of all time documented.
That's why this year we're
celebrating 50 years of hip hop.
(audience clapping)
- That is a cool story!
I didn't know that.
I grew up in church and I feel like
the first time I ever heard
a preacher really preach,
that's what it reminds me of.
Hip hop and rapping in general,
it reminds me of just
somebody that is so good
at sharing their testimony,
like what's happening in their
lives and how it's evolved.
It's almost like preaching
in a sense to me,
that's how I received it as a kid.
- And it's a call and response, you know?
- Yeah, it's really nice.
- Between the MC
and the audience.
For example, if I said to the audience,
"When I say Kelly, you say Clarkson."
You would say, when I say Kelly, you say-
- [Audience] Clarkson!
- There you go.
- Yeah, I like it!
- [DJ Cassidy] There you go.
- We didn't plan that, but
I just like hearing my name.
(all laughing)
Well, Cassidy, you've done a
ton of big shows and projects,
so what do you have going on right now?
- So during The Pandemic,
I created a series called "Pass the Mic",
where I would invite iconic
hip hop stars onto my show
to sing along with their
most iconic records.
And after 10 episodes, the
show took the world by storm
and featured 220 of the most legendary
hip hop and r&b superstars of all time.
And this year, 2023, I'm taking
"Pass The Mic" on the road
with "Pass The Mic Live" to a
theater or an arena near you.
So it's a very exciting year
for me, and for "Pass The Mic."
And I'm gonna be passing the mic
to so many hip hop icons
throughout the year.
(audience clapping)
- That's incredible, man.
What a great idea.